cosecant of X we'll just start with the
basic one
we know that cosecant is the reciprocal
of the sine graph so what we're gonna do
is we're gonna graph the sine graph to
use it as a guide okay so if we graph
the sine graph we know it looks like
this
okay and it keeps going alright and so
on like that but if we look at the sine
graph here say where sine is equal to
zero right
what's one divided by zero it's
undefined right so what happens is you
get a vertical asymptote okay same thing
here at zero what's one divided by 0 its
undefined you get a vertical asymptote
so wherever the graph okay the sine
graph is crossing the x axis that's
where your vertical asymptotes are gonna
go now over here with sine okay the
parent function for sine okay it goes
between negative 1 and Y over here RC
sine is 1 what's 1 divided by 1 it's 1
right say over here it's 1/2 what's 1
divided by 1/2
that's 2 ok so you can see 1/2 - so what
happens is we get a graph that looks
like this ok and like this so we just
graph the sine graph to help us okay we
use it as a guide to get our graph for
for cosecant okay so over here this is
let's see this is PI this is 2 pi 3 PI
like that okay so that's the basic graph
for cosecant now for cosine it's the
exact same idea so say for example we
want to graph secant okay secant is a
reciprocal of cosine ok so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna graph the cosine
graph okay which starts at the maximum
goes to 0 down to the minimum back to 0
back to the max like that and of course
it repeats so we can keep going like
this okay
just draw a little bit more than one
cycle and then again wherever it crosses
the
x-axis because this is zero we can't
divide by zero we're gonna get vertical
asymptotes okay so there's your vertical
asymptotes okay and again we can label
this this is a PI over two this is PI 3
PI over 2 2 pi okay and so on and then
our graph is gonna coincide at this
maximum point and at this minimum point
okay they coincide they just cross right
at that one point okay so a quick way to
get your basic cosecant and secant graph
by graphing the cosine or sine and then
taking the reciprocal and like so okay
let me show you a little bit more
complicated example so you can get a
sense of how to do some of the more
difficult problems let me just erase
this real quick so say we want to graph
y equals two cosecant one-half X okay
it's a pretty good problem right what
we're gonna do is we're gonna graph y
equals two sine one-half X okay so what
does that mean it means the amplitude is
gonna be two we're gonna graph our sine
graph okay like that I'm gonna graph a
little bit more just to give us a little
bit better diagram here a better picture
and remember the period is 2 pi is a
normal period divided by B this is your
B value here one half so that comes out
to 4 pi so what that means is that it's
completing one cycle one period in 4 pi
okay so that means this would be 2 pi 1
pi 3 pi okay so I'm just dividing this
into 4 pieces okay now we can go ahead
and graph our cosecant graph we just
wherever it crosses the x-axis we're
drawing our asymptotes like so okay
wherever the sine graph is crossing the
x-axis and then we can just draw our
cosecant graph
and that's it you got it so I'll show
you one more example with secant we're
going to do a little bit more
challenging one was always have to step
it up a notch right
start easy and then build on that let's
do one where it's been translated okay
so let's look at this one let's say we
want to graph y equals secant X minus PI
over 2 plus 1 okay so what does the PI
over 2 do what does the one do this one
remember has the opposite effect it's
shifting right PI over 2 this one has
the same effect on the graph as shifting
up one so what I'm gonna do is I'm going
to start by graphing the cosine graph
okay now follow me here I'm going to
graph the cosine graph just of using
this graph here okay so cosine looks
like this if you need to revert review
back go back to the cosine and sine
videos if you need some help with this
but it starts at the max 0 min 0 max
that's one cycle 2 pi okay this is PI
over 2 pi 3 PI over 2 ok like that and
the minus PI over 2 this is shifting it
actually positive PI over 2 right PI
over 2 so each of these points is going
to go to the right okay one step okay
like that like that look at that look at
that okay so at this point would be
right here so now your graph looks like
this
all right so so far with me okay so but
now remember we said that wherever it
crosses the x-axis that's where the
vertical asymptotes are going to be so
right here okay that's where our
vertical asymptotes are okay and now
what I'm going to do is I'm just gonna
lightly draw in the seeking graph okay
like this and this keeps going by the
way so I can draw arrows on here so it
keeps going it approaches the asymptote
but doesn't touch doesn't cross but wait
a second you say what about the one okay
what do we do with the one well the one
tells us to shift the graph up one so
all these points are gonna go up one
right so now the graphs gonna look like
this okay and then same thing over here
this is gonna go up one so it's actually
touching right there right up one like
that okay and the asymptotes are in the
same place so that's how I would do it I
would start graphing this cosine or sine
graph depending if you're using secant
or cosecant and then I would do the
shift okay this is the phase shift left
and right wherever it crosses the x axis
draw your vertical asymptotes go ahead
and draw in your secant graph you can
draw it dotted or in a different color
or whatever you prefer and then you can
shift it up or down so that's what I
would recommend
that's the secant graph there if you
have other questions go back and review
the sine and cosine graphs if you have
questions on how to get the graphs in
the period the period for seeking in
cosecant is the same as for sine and
cosine it's two pi so whatever this
number is right here in front of the X
variable you can use that formula period
equals two pi divided by B okay this is
the B in this case that's one okay to
find out how long it takes for it to
complete one cycle okay I'll see you in
the next video if you have comments or
questions or things that you'd like me
to discuss more or helpful hints that I
can use to incorporate into these videos
feel free to leave me a comment
or send me an email or let me know and
I'll see you in the next video